gracias por continuar en la pantalla de
france 24 estamos de regreso para hablar
de las implicancias económicas de la
crisis ruso-ucraniana y para eso nos
acompaña por supuesto nuestro compañero
jorge hurtado jorge bueno como decíamos
vamos a hablar de esta crisis que tiene
puesto a los ojos de todo el mundo sobre
ella y hablamos de las posibles
sanciones que ya se barajan no desde la
unión europea y eeuu contra rusia así es
y es que con esta reciente escalada de
las tensiones de eeuu y sus aliados
europeos han dicho públicamente que
golpearían las finanzas rusas y invade a
ucrania y entre las opciones está
excluir a rusia del sistema financiero
swift este sistema permite transferir
dinero de un banco a otro en todo el
mundo y es parte de las medidas
incluidas en la llamada madre de todas
las sanciones que una comisión
bipartidista del senado de eeuu ya
prepara en 2014 cuando rusia invadió y
anexión crimea ucrania fue una de las
opciones que se mencionó pero rusia dijo
que sacarlos del sistema equivaldría a
una declaración de guerra esto porque
les complicaría sobre todo recibir los
beneficios internacionales de la
producción de petróleo y gas que
representan para reducir a más del 40%
del total de sus ingresos pero nos
preguntamos qué tan grande es el sistema
financiero ruso y cómo afectaría una
sanción de este tipo se lo preguntamos a
eric béjar villegas el doctor y profesor
en economía y esto no dijo el sistema
financiero ruso
equivale más o menos a 1.4 billones de
dólares es decir es el 99 por ciento del
pib de rusia estamos hablando de más o
menos unos 300 bancos de los cuales
248 tienen licencia universal es decir
que tienen una conexión con el mundo
externo más o menos el 10 por ciento es
de propiedad extranjera y el 18 por
ciento es de propiedad de digamos de los
privados pero en rusia lo que sí es
importante sobre el sistema financiero
ruso es que el 50 por ciento es dominado
por dos bancos y estos dos bancos son
estatales cuando hacemos la suma de todo
lo que tiene el estado del sistema
financiero ruso tengamos más o menos el
73 por ciento eso significa que
cualquier presión política se va a poder
transmitir rápidamente el sistema
financiero de rusia jorge hablemos ahora
de otro de los puntos centrales de este
conflicto que tiene que ver con la
preocupación que hay en europa por el
suministro de gas ruso así es y bueno es
que detener los flujos de gas hacia
europa es un es un as bajo la manga que
tiene todavía moscú si occidente impone
algún tipo de sanciones sin precedentes
varios analistas creen que el bloque
europeo estén menos preparados que moscú
en este eventual escenario rusia es el
mayor proveedor de energía de la unión
europea cerca del 40 por ciento de las
importaciones de gas europeas vienen de
rusia así como casi un tercio de sus
importaciones de crudo en el centro del
debate está la autorización del
gasoducto nord stream 2 que va de rusia
a alemania y pese a que europa y eeuu ya
buscan nuevos proveedores no hay certeza
de que pueden responder de inmediato a
la demanda en un caso de suspensión de
este suministro esto nos dijo nuestro
invitado el día de hoy al respecto
cuando enviamos el caso enormes fin 2
estamos hablando un gasoducto que está
construido que le pertenece a gazprom es
decir a esta grande empresa estatal rusa
pero que a la vez a pesar de estar ya
construido no está todavía en
funcionamiento pero que nos recuerda
aquí en alemania claramente que
dependemos de la de suministro de gas
desde rusia en un 51 por ciento si
miramos toda la unión europea estamos
viendo una dependencia de más o menos
del 30 por ciento de toda la reunión de
rusia que va a pasar entonces si
realmente se llega a escalar el
conflicto y rusia deja de enviar legaz a
la unión europea sobre todo ahora en el
invierno que frío pues ya digamos va a
continuar al menos un mes o dos meses
habría un problema de serio porque no se
podrían emplear estos recursos de gas
para poder calentar por ejemplo las
viviendas entonces eso coincide con otro
problema que es que estamos justamente
en un momento de alza de precios de
energía que golpea fuertemente a los
hogares y eso obviamente puede generar
unas convulsiones políticas que no sé
qué en este momento bueno y contanos
jorge hay otros ámbitos en los que
podría impactar este conflicto así de
santiago bueno por ejemplo rusia
suministra alrededor del 40 por ciento
del paladio mundial este metal es
necesario para los catalizadores de los
vehículos que limiten las emisiones
nocivas también suministra cerca del 30
por ciento del titanio que es clave para
la industria aerospacial empresas como
la europea airbus abastecen la mitad de
su titanio en rusia y la americana point
lo utiliza para fabricar sus aviones
hasta ahora las tensiones en europa del
este- mantienen los mercados bursátiles
con alta volatilidad y sin duda
seguiremos ampliando los efectos
económicos de este conflicto en las
próximas semanas interesantísima crónica
jorge sigan y formándose en france 24 y
en france mit y cuatro.com